well you're gonna come back - well
[Applause]
[Music]
alright folks it is time for us to do a
Doctor Who list as selected by my
supporters over at patreon thanks so
much everybody so this time I'm going to
be ranking the regenerations now let me
be specific about this because when it
comes to regenerations
I figure there's basically three things
that you can rank you can rank the
episode in which the regeneration occurs
you can rank the first story of the
doctor coming out of the regeneration
I've actually done that already and you
can rank the regeneration itself looking
at it in isolation as a scene the way
was executed maybe the immediate
circumstances that led to it but not
bagging it down with all of the story
that came before because nearly every
regeneration story honestly the
narrative could work even without the
regeneration happening at the end and it
would be unaffected so we're dealing
with the regenerations themselves here
and this list was interesting to compile
because I realized that much like when I
rank the doctors there are only a couple
that I have genuine issues with and then
it's just a preference after that
because only the bottom few of these are
ones that I would consider to be
genuinely bad alright there's 13 of
these to do let's get the super obvious
bottom slot out of the way that's the
regeneration from The Sixth Doctor into
the seventh column Baker was
unceremoniously dumped from the show and
unsurprisingly
he said no when they asked him to come
back to briefly film a regeneration
scene for at least art of Sylvester
McCoy Sarah you can't blame the guy at
all so instead of having any
situation that builds and results in the
doctor making some kind of sacrifice or
being in a situation that he can't quite
come out of alive whether he meant to be
that way or not or or facing down a
daring foe instead we just get the
TARDIS gets jostles around a bit and he
lands on the floor and regenerates it's
really lame its lamé on multiple levels
and it was a disservice both to the end
of Baker's era and the beginning of
McCoys it's just a shame now that is
honestly the only legitimately
bad one although the next one up from
that which is number 12 has a slightly
similar thing and that is the
regeneration of the war doctor into the
ninth doctor and the reason that one is
so low is because it feels incomplete
pretty much because Eccleston made the
decision not to join and be part of the
50th anniversary although honestly if he
had we might not have the war doctor at
all they just would have used the ninth
doctor for that but regardless we didn't
get to the other side of the
regeneration we just saw hurt and we let
into it starts to turn to X and then
just we just cut away and while it's not
actively bad the way that the one I
mentioned before the six into seven was
its it is incomplete and also it is
simply it's not a bad thing that it goes
out of its way to reference the original
regeneration but it means that it is
inherently derivative so it ends up way
down here next up this one this is gonna
be controversial mmm-hmm the
regeneration of the Tenth Doctor into
the 11th so Tennant de Smith I'm sorry I
don't
especially care for this regeneration I
don't love the circumstances under
[ __ ] happens or more specifically I
don't like the doctors hissy fit
particularly I while I'm not as down on
the extended goodbye sequence as some
people are with him visiting all the
various companions is self-indulgent is
really the word for it and then to end
with I don't want to go that honestly is
what I dislike more than anything else
and I it never hit me hard that the
whole I don't want to go it never hit me
hard I expected it to at the time at
first arrow was shocked that it didn't
and I didn't dislike it at the time but
as time has gone on I'm just looked at
I'm gone no it doesn't work now again I
don't actually think it's bad but for my
taste and what I prefer and care for
yeah no it's it's way down here in the
11th spot and be so many people yelling
at me next up number 10 the Seventh
Doctor into the eighth doctor
so this would be from the Doctor Who TV
movie of the 90s the own the for a long
time only visual appearance of Paul
McGann's eighth doctor and the doctor
basically just steps out of his target
Freudian slip steps out of his TARDIS
and gets gunned down on the streets of
San Francisco
it's very unceremoniously way I can kind
of appreciate it because it is a very
ordinary death and I kind of like the
idea that the doctor isn't always going
to die quote-unquote under extraordinary
circumstances of great heroism something
feels right about having at least one
fairly innocuous unspectacular
regeneration on the books doesn't mean I
love it that's why it's as low as it is
but I do have a bit of an appreciation
for it in the context of the
regeneration as a whole
next up number nine the Fourth Doctor
into the fifth the end of Tom Baker's
era in the beginning
of Peter Davison and this one again it's
not bad but it's just a weird outlier
cuz they did the whole thing with the
watcher this like ghostly figure that
had been lurking in the background of
the story up to that point and then it
comes down and joins with the doctor for
the regeneration because it is the
doctor or maybe it's the next
incarnation of the doctor and they merge
in them there's Davison it's it's weird
I get that they were trying to make
things a little bit more momentous
because Tom Baker held the role for
longer than anyone had up to that point
and still held the role for longer than
anyone else did but it is just such an
outlier and it at this point in time it
doesn't feel momentous it feels weird
for the sake of being weird and well not
bad it's just like okay I'm not sure why
you did that number eight the first
doctor into the second the one that
started it all now in many ways this is
also kind of an unremarkable
regeneration because nothing really sets
it off the doctor just says that his
body's wearing a bit thin and that just
kicks it off there but this was the
first time it was done it shouldn't have
been this overly spectacular thing it
just needed to establish the concept in
bodies wearing a bit thin that tells you
everything you need to know that when
he's run out of time run out of strength
run out of energy run out of life he can
come back and then we got in this case
the second doctor it's simple and simple
is not always a bad thing number seven
the second doctor into the third so this
gave us Patrick Troughton into John
Pertwee and there's a lot I like about
the circumstance of this and it suits
the second doctor a lot that there's
actually he doesn't sacrifice himself he
doesn't you know lose to a foe he has
the regeneration forced on him
by the time lords who he is terrified of
and he tries to stall and he delays and
he's this petulant child until the Time
Lords get fed up and just send him off
and and make the choice for him as to
what he's gonna be like and while in the
grand scheme of regenerations again not
maybe particularly spectacular
incredibly appropriate for the second
doctor it's very fitting and it's it's
well matched that way of doing it too at
the end of his era number six the
twelfth doctor into the thirteenth Peter
Capaldi into Jodie Whittaker I debated
on the placement of this one and I did
ask I initially had it actually quite a
bit lower and then I asked are you
knocking it just because of one bit of
the speech that you don't love and then
I moved it actually quite a bit higher
I'm like are you boosting it just
because Capaldi's currently your
favorite doctor and remember that might
not stay the case forever has changed
before and so it ultimately settled
about here
first of all Capaldi can deliver
speeches like nobody's freakin business
and most of this speech is really good
and I am gonna focus on the speech here
as opposed to these circumstances
because actually the circumstances it's
not a third generation aren't even in
this story
they're from the previous one and he
just delayed it through the course of
twice upon a time so the circumstances
actually don't even really come into
play in you know in terms of when we
actually see the dang thing he gets some
goodbyes not dissimilar to Tennant but
the fact that they come to him and he's
not you know taking a tour of his own
life makes it feel at least for me a bit
less self-indulgent and a bit more
bittersweet without trying to hammer
sadness on to you and his speech is very
bittersweet as well and I really like
the idea of him giving advice to the new
doctor never ever heat pears but you
know remember
hate is always foolish and love is
always wise the only thing that I don't
love is the line about children hearing
his name it's a cute enough idea but I
don't feel like that thought flows with
the rest of what's going on it it feels
jarring I always felt it was a bit
jarring and that's what the one thing
that keeps us from getting any higher
here we go top five third doctor into
the fourth Pertwee into Tom Baker that's
here Sarah Jane I mean that's that's
that's a big part of it right there you
know the doctor went on one last
adventure he faced a you know very
powerful foe and it was too much and
this sweet moment between him and Sarah
Jane where she's you know she doesn't
really know what's going on and he has
that line and again like classic era
didn't do big speeches around the
regenerations but when they got it right
they found the exact right thing to say
in a few words to capture the moment and
you've got the Brigadier on hand who has
a bit more of a here we go again thing
going on which is kind of a nice
antidote to remind you that this doesn't
have to be just sad like we've been
through this before we'll come out the
other side we'll be okay and then of
course just just him changing into Tom
Baker's ridiculous face yeah it just
works
number four eighth doctor into the war
doctor this one it almost feels like
cheating because the quote unquote story
it takes place in is so short it
basically is the entire context for the
regeneration because unlike all the
other instances where I said there's a
story and then I regeneration happens at
the end this is because it's a mini
episode is just the regeneration
circumstances in situations so all of
its on the table and I love night as a
doctor I freaking love it I love the REE
that he regenerates simply because he
refused to leave when he could get this
woman off this crashing ship and she
didn't want his help at that point she
knew they were both gonna die and she
was happy for that and he still didn't
leave he still tried to talk her on
until the TARDIS to save her life until
it killed them both and that speaks very
well to him
I love his snark when dealing with you
know this order of women who can bring
him back you know they tell him he's got
just a few minutes left and he's
complaining about how much time that is
anyone four chests bring me knitting
it's it's great but you can also catch
the strain in his voice that he knows he
is out of time and he isn't thrilled
about making the choice to turn into a
warrior but it's the choice that needs
to be made and while we don't get a ton
with John Hurt after that because you
know we had to have to reflection
because they they were using old footage
to make it look like young John Hurt so
yeah we weren't gonna get a full proper
thing the build-up is so good the fact
that we only get a look of him in the
reflection that's honestly enough I mean
it's more than we got out of the war
doctor into the 9th so hey I just love
this thing so much number three the
eleventh Doctor into the 12th as much as
I do think Capaldi's the best speech
giver of modern era Doctor Who and also
as much as I actually honestly really
don't care for the time of the doctor
like at all but once he's on the TARDIS
and the combination of him seeing young
Amelia
of having his goodbye with this vision
of Amy and his reassurance to Clara
hi adorn the thingy says about you know
um you always have to remember all the
people who you used to be because we're
always changing like that's just
something that like rings really true to
me anyways and he delivers it really
well with this sort of soft bittersweet
tone and I like that this was an
instance where the regeneration was just
snap and there it is just boom and now
he's somebody else I like that over the
you know the extended uh it's all light
shining out of him ah no boom sudden and
he's gone again just it just feels right
in that moment oh that's real good
number two the 9th doctor into the 10th
Eccleston to Tennant first of all the
circumstances saving the life of his
companion the the sadness behind sort of
the Glee he has you know he's making
jokes you know what if I have two heads
what if I don't have a head imagine me
without a head but you can tell there's
a sadness behind that and there's a
strain and there's a tension and part of
him scared which we don't always get and
Eccleston really gave his all in the
time he played the part the the brief
time he played the part and I really do
think he nailed such an amazing mix of a
lot of different feelings and emotions
and brought them all to the forefront in
the last moments and assuring Rose that
she was fantastic and giving himself a
little self-indulgent moment to say so
was I and finally if you've been keeping
track you know what it is number one
the regeneration of the fifth doctor
into the sixth Davison into Colin Baker
in the caves of Androzani which is a
fantastic episode in and of itself but
even setting all that aside and focusing
on the regeneration he dies to save his
companion this is what this is what
tenants regeneration wanted to be this
kind of sacrifice and it's what
Eccleston's regeneration came very close
to matching but this is the best because
not only does he sacrifice himself so
that the companion will live he does it
basically without hesitation even having
in the back of his mind fear that this
regeneration isn't going to go well
something's going to go wrong but he
still does it doesn't hesitate because
that's who he is that's what he does and
I feel like more than any other
regeneration this is a summation of who
the doctor is not just Davison's doctor
but the doctor period whoever the doctor
is this is ultimately what it boils down
to the savior of universes willingly
dying to save one person and not
hesitating to do it that's why it's my
number one pick for the best
regeneration what are your thoughts on
it other than yelling at me for putting
tenon so low which people love to do
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it once it's up to do as well
because you can like subscribe so warmly
on patreon and get to vote on list
topics like this one plus there's merch
and all sorts of stuff it's the holidays
I have a peel box I'm just saying but
you know what you also don't have to do
any of that because at the end of the
day you are the council I just won the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]